six mois plus tard tamar alter escaut
bonsoir 24 février tout ça a commencé
on va voir une carte on la première
question qu'on se pose c'est où on est
où en sont les choses sur le terrain
parce qu'on se dit après six mois de
guerre il ya des évents ya des avancées
çà doit en valoir la peine mais si on
regarde la carte la russie les troupes
russes que prend ce moment à peu près 20
à 22 23 % du territoire ukrainien mais
ça ça comprend regarder au soudan rouge
de la crimée qui était déjà
sous contrôle russe et des parties
importantes du donbass lougansk et
d'honnête qui était déjà sous
l'occupation russe par la voix des mille
des militants pro russe donc dans les
faits depuis le 24 février depuis ce
célèbre discours de vladimir poutine et
les premières frappes la russie
occupe et a réussi à avancer sur 13 %
seulement du territoire ukrainien si on
le compare à l'objectif qu'ils s'étaient
donnés dans ce discours
des gains de presque rien mais mais très
mais très dramatique on s'entend comme
comme conséquence si les russes n'avance
pas davantage c'est que l'otan est
derrière l'ukraine washington est
derrière lui craint la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est est-ce que cet appui
de l'ouest va durer elle appuie oui je
pense qu'il est acquis puisqu'il faut
pas non plus négliger la rapidité avec
laquelle les membres de l'otan se sont
rangées ont passé les chapeaux et ont
fourni de l'aide à l'ukraine se sert si
remarquable dans les guerres modernes si
on veut comme réaction la solidarité va
rester mais est-ce qu'on a les moyens de
fournir les armes à la hauteur des
ambitions des élèves qui se c'est une
autre question aujourd'hui le sujet
lundi à participer sur une conférence
sur la crim il savait ce qu'il a dit non
ce soir pas la table des pourparlers à
moins qu'ils aient un retrait des
troupes de nos territoires 5 la crimée
et on n'accepte rien en termes de paix
que la crimée on est prêt à aller la
rechercher à n'importe quel coût avec
n'importe quel moyen donc oui l'aide
internationale de l'occident est de la
russie à l ukraine à se défendre a
limité les dégâts mais c'est
certainement pas assez reprendre pour
reprendre pour gagner la guerre tels que
the lens qui promet aux ukrainiens le
faire il n'est pas dans une logique vous
de le dire de concession et lundi ce qui
met la russie n'ont plus honte réussi
non plus effectivement mais si
washington mettait toute la gomme et lui
dit bon mais là il va falloir que tu
laisses une partie de la crimée une
partie du débat il n'aurait pas beaucoup
de choix est ce que c'est ça la voie de
sortie les deux possibilités a fait le
plein parce que poutine peut demain dire
mobilisation générale envoyer des
millions d'hommes aux combats ça ça vous
ça vous ça va changer la donne sur le
terrain là alors on s'entend là il y
aura plus la stagnation à laquelle on
assiste mais en termes de solutions pour
la paix
il n'ya pas mille solutions soit on va
voir au cours des prochains mois
des attaques plus féroce donc une qu'on
appelle une intensité dans les combats
où on va s'asseoir à la table puis on va
discuter sérieusement de façon
diplomatique d'une solution à long terme
pour la paix c'est ce qui va arriver et
si on pousse de lenski à accepter des
compromis c'est parce qu'on juge qu'on
n'aura pas les moyens est d'abord de
l'aider à atteindre ses objectifs et on
pourra plus justifier nos propres
populations
paul canada le canada offre pas autant
que les états unis et l'europe l'on
s'entend mais on pourra plus justifiée
de financer cette guerre at vitam
aeternam mais tout est dans l'air en ce
moment et comme une immobilité
actuellement sans le moyen qui est
suspendu oui jusqu'où ira washington
dans le plus à dire dans le temps oui
ils diront parce que gbagbo ne sera pas
un jour ou un autre devra reculer
territorialement ne sera pas aussi et de
façon évidente mais c'est une
possibilité vous connaissez bien la
russie venant tamara est ce que poutine
son pouvoir est érodée ou pas mais je
pense qu'on peut se poser la question à
la surface non sein de la population non
parce qu'elle est
les censures et moi j'étais en russie au
mois de juin pour aller fermer le bureau
et puis les gens ne parlent pas la
guerre et une peur mais avec
l'assassinât le week-end dernier de
cette commentatrice pro guerre
impérialiste très pro poutine
dans un attentat à la voiture piégée on
peut se poser une question parce que
c'est une des thèses explorer ce qui a
pas des groupes souterrain pour connu
parce qu'ils ont d'ailleurs revendiqué
l'attentât qui travaillent de façon très
radicales pour déstabiliser le bois le
pouvoir ceux ci une hypothèse qu'on ne
pourra jamais écarté qui pourrait causer
de sérieux problèmes à vladimir poutine
mais pour l'instant on n'a pas de
preuves tangibles pour déterminer si ça
y est de pouvoir vous allez vous rendre
en ukraine d'ici quelques jours on va
évidemment suivre tout ça camara merci
beaucoup vous en prie au revoir